[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance guess what Donald Trump did
on June 9th 2016 on the same day
probably just a few hours after his son
and his son-in-law and his soon-to-be
campaign Chairman spent 20 to 30 minutes
listening to a Kremlin linked attorney
who reportedly wanted to give the Trump
campaign dirt on Hillary Clinton and the
DNC guess what Donald Trump's senior was
up to in another part of Trump Tower he
sent out what all evidence suggests was
his first tweet specifically about
Hillary Clinton's missing 33,000 emails
at 4:40 p.m. June 9th 2016 Trump replied
to her suggestion that he delete his
account by writing how long did it take
your staff of 823 people to think that
up then he added and where are your
33,000 emails that you deleted jeepers
now lots of stuff happened on Thursday
June 9th 2016 on that date Judicial
Watch released a deposition from a
Clinton aide who said she could not
confirm whether or not emails had been
deleted on that day Trump went to a
fundraiser on that day he met with
Reince Priebus and on that day Donald
Trump jr. and Jared Kushner and the man
would become Trump campaign chairman
eleven days later all met in Trump Tower
with a Putin linked attorney from Russia
even though Trump jr. claims he didn't
know her name beforehand even though
Trump jr. claims he never told Kushner
or mana for what the meeting was about
even though nobody called the FBI to say
hey there was a foreign attorney or
somebody just here trying to peddle
information maybe this is espionage jr.
certainly didn't tell the authorities
what the meeting was about or that had
happened
neither did Mann afford neither did
Kushner and Kushner didn't initially
mention it on a national security
clearance forum on which he should have
mentioned it they all Stonewall for 13
months the campaign never met with
anybody connected to the Russians about
Hillary or hacking emails or poisoning
the election or anything else well other
than on June 9th 2016 and that meeting
with the
Russian attorney which Trump jr. ended
only when he determined quote no details
or supporting information was provided
or even offered it quickly became clear
that she had no meaningful information
well jr. claims she had no supporting or
meaningful information last Saturday he
was claiming the meeting was about
Americans adopting Russian children in
March he was claiming that there had
never been any meeting but there was
certainly the same day and unless you
think jr. and Kushner and manna Ford and
the Russian Attorney met after the close
of that business day sometime not long
after that meeting daddy is suddenly
tweeting about 33,000 emails that you
deleted funny thing is June 9th 2016 was
the start of Trump's obsession with
Hillary's quote 33,000 emails the one
that climax did his press conference on
July 26th when he stared into the camera
and said Russia if you're listening I
hope you're able to find the emails
another funny thing is I can't find any
reference to Trump ever using that
figure 33,000 prior to the tweet On June
9th the same day as the jr. Kushner mana
fork meeting with the Russian lawyer in
fact while there were lots of references
by lots of people to quote deleted
unquote Clinton emails in 2015 and 2016
that June 9th tweet is not just the
first time cup used that number it is
also the first time he used the term
deleted same day presumably soon after
his son met with the Russian lawyer
33,000 deleted emails however did he get
hold of that such coincidences
gaali on any given day lots of things
happen does it necessarily mean they're
all connected let alone that they're
necessarily cause and effect on the
other hand it also doesn't mean they're
necessarily not cause and effect
resist piece